[Music]
um are we closer than ever to a friends
reunion ah I know cute issue co-stars
and real-life BFFs Jennifer Aniston
Lisa Kudrow and Courtney Cox aka Rachel
Phoebe and Monica celebrated a girls
night on Sunday and gifted us with the
selfies to prove it seemingly teasing us
that they are halfway there to an
official reunion in the caption it's
perfect
Lisa's caption left fans wondering if
she was hinting at a possible friend's
reboots add in Matt LeBlanc Matthew
Perry and David Schwimmer and we have a
full-fledged reunion do a friends
reunion okay Oh Jennifer recently said
she's open to bringing back the 90s
sitcom during a chat with Ellen
DeGeneres I told you this I would do it
mm-hmm we have a lot of oh I know the
picture shows up I forget the girls were
doing yeah and the boys would do it I'm
sure
listen and while the show may have gone
off the air 15 years ago
[Applause]
Jennifer said she still thinks Ross and
Rachel are each other's lobsters during
a stop by The Today Show yes they're
back together
absolutely when et caught up with Jenn
in June she explained why she had a
change of heart about doing a reunion
for 16 years we've been asking you about
a friend's rebooted now you said maybe
and now I know and now you did this to
us
you did this well you know know was
getting me nowhere maybe was getting me
in nowhere so I don't know I thought I'd
try us see what happened
could it having you anything can happen
I have no idea though there's no plans
in them in the immediate future
so everyone calm down yeah oran keeper
don't and
don't stay excited and possibly
something will happen
[Music]
[Applause]